ما قيمه خطط الحرب ان فقدت سريتها فالسريه
قد تكون اهم من الخطه نفسها وتسريبها يعني
هزيمه مسبقه في المعركه قنبله مدويه
فجرتها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تشير لان اهم
مؤسسه عسكريه في العالم وهي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لم تنجح في الحفاظ على سريه
وثائق متعلقه بالحرب الاوكرانيه الاكثر من
ذلك هو ان هذه الوثائق باتت بين يدي الطرف
الاخر في الحرب
روسيا فالوثائق انتشرت على نطاق واسع على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في روسيا ما يشكل
ضربه موجعه للخطط الاوكرانيه في الحرب
فعلى ماذا تحتوي هذه الوثائق تحديدا
الوثائق تقدم لمحه سريعه لما قد تحتاجه
القوات الاوكرانيه في المعركه المرتقبه ضد
روسيا والتي يتم تداولها تحت مسمى حرب
الربيع وتكشف الوثائق عن توجه اوكرانيا
نحو مواصله الاعتماد على منظومته مارس
لصواريخ المدفعيه التي اثبتت فعاليتها في
المعارك ومن بين الاسرار التي كشفت عنها
الوثائق ايضا تشكيل اثني عشره وحده قتاليه
اوكرانيه يتم تدريبها من قبل الولايات
المتحده وحلفاء اخرين في الناتو وتتحدث
الوثائق ايضا عن الجدول الزمني لتسليم
المعدات العسكريه لجيش الاوكراني فضلا عن
معلومات عسكريه اخرى
عمليه تسريب الوثائق هذه قد تدخل ضمن
دائره الحرب النفسيه والاستراتيجيه بين
الطرفين فنقلا عن الصحيفه دائما فان موسكو
قد تكونوا تعمدت نشر الوثائق وتلاعبت في
بعض جزئياتها من اجل تمويه الجيش
الاوكراني وبعثره اوراقه وبعيدا عن مدى
تاثير هذه الوثائق المسربه على اطوار
المعارك فالاكيد ان الحرب النفسيه
والاستراتيجيه باتت تاخذ حيزا اكبر في هذا
الصراع المتواصل وسما الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات